see it'd be interesting if that theory
of mind
is what leads to consciousness in the
way we think about it
is the richness of the subjective
experience that is consciousness
i have a inkling sense that that only
exists because we're social creatures
that that doesn't come uh with this with
the hardware and the software any in the
beginning
that's like uh that's learned
as an effective uh tool for
communication almost
like we we think we i think we think uh
that consciousness is fundamental
and uh maybe it's not
now there's a a bunch of folks kind of
criticize the idea that the
illusion of consciousness is
consciousness that
it is just a facade we use to
to uh help us construct theories of mind
you almost put yourself in the world
as a subjective being and that
experience you want to
richly experience it as an individual
person so that i could
empathize with your experience i find
that notion compelling
mostly because it allows you to then
create robots
that become conscious not by being quote
unquote conscious but by
just learning to fake it till they make
it
is uh creative you know present a facade
of consciousness
and with it with the task of uh making
that facade
very convincing to us humans and thereby
it will become conscious
have a sense ins that in some way
that will make them conscious if they're
sufficiently
convincing to humans
is there some element of that that you
uh
do you find convincing this is a
much harder set of questions
and deep end of the pool than starting
with the aliens was
um we went from aliens to consciousness
this is not the trajectory i was
expecting nor you
but let us walk a while we we can walk a
while and i don't think we will
do it justice so what do we mean by
consciousness versus conscious
self-reflective
awareness what do we mean by awareness
qualia
theory of mind there's a lot of terms
that we think of as slightly
different things and um
subjectivity first person uh
i i don't remember exactly the quote but
i remember when
reading when sam harris wrote the book
free will and then dennett critiqued it
and then there was some writing back and
forth between the two because normally
they're on the same side
of kind of arguing for critical thinking
and
logical fallacies and philosophy of
science against
supernatural ideas and here
dennett believed there is something like
free will he is a
determinist compatibilist but no
consciousness an ex a radical
limitativist
and sam was saying no there is
consciousness but there's no free will
and that's like the most
fundamental kinds of axiomatic senses
they disagreed on but neither of them
could say it was because the other one
didn't understand the philosophy of
science
or logical fallacies and and they kind
of spoke past each other and at the end
if i remember correctly sam said
something i thought was quite
insightful which was to the effect of it
seems it
because they weren't making any progress
in shared understanding it seems that we
simply have different intuitions about
this
and what you could see was that
what the words meant right at the level
of symbol grounding
might be quite different uh one of them
might have had
deeply different enough life experiences
that what is being referenced and then
also different associations of what the
words mean this is why
when trying to address these things
charles sanders purse said the first
philosophy has to be semiotics
because if you don't get semiotics right
we end up importing different ideas and
bad ideas right into the nature of the
language that we're using
and then it's very hard to do
epistemology or ontology together
so i'm saying this to say why i don't
think we're going to get very far is i
think
we would have to go very slowly in terms
of defining what we mean by
words and fundamental concepts um well
and also allowing our minds to drift
together for time so that our
definitions of these terms
align i think there's some
there's a beauty that some people enjoy
with sam
that he is quite stubborn
on his definitions of terms without
often clearly revealing that definition
so in his mind he can
like you could sense that he can deeply
understand what he means
exactly by term like free will and
consciousness and you're right he's very
he's very specific in in fascinating
ways that
not only does he think that free will is
an illusion
he thinks he's able not thanks he says
he's able to just remove himself from
the experience of free will
and just be like for minutes at a time
hours at a time like
really experience as if he has no free
will like he's uh
a leaf flowing down the river
and given that he's very sure that
consciousness is fundamental
so here's a this conscious leaf that's
subjectively experiencing the floating
and yet there's no ability to control
and make any decisions for its
for itself it's only a um
the decisions have all been made
there's some aspect to which the
terminology there perhaps is the problem
so that's a particular kind of
meditative experience and
the people in the vedantic tradition and
some of the buddhist traditions
thousands of years ago described similar
experiences and somewhat similar
conclusions
some slightly different there are other
types of phenomenal experience
that uh are the phenomenal experience of
pure agency
and you know like the the catholic
theologian
but evolutionary theorist tara de
chardon describes this
and that rather than a creator agent god
in the beginning there's a creative
impulse or a creative process
and he was would go into a type of
meditation that identified as the pure
essence of that kind of creative process
um and i think the types of experiences
we've had and then one the types of
experiences we've had make a big deal to
the nature of how we do symbol grounding
the other thing is the types of
experiences we have can't
not be interpreted through our existing
interpretive frames
and most of the time our interpretive
frames are unknown even to us some of
them
and so so this is a tricky
this is a tricky topic um so i guess
there's a bunch of directions we could
go with it but i want to come back to
what the
um impulse was that was interesting
around what is consciousness and how
does it relate to us
as social beings and how does it relate
to
the possibility of consciousness with it
ais right
you're keeping us on track which is uh
which is wonderful
you're a wonderful hiking partner okay
yes let's go back to the initial impulse
of uh what is consciousness and how does
the social impulse connect to
consciousness is consciousness a uh
consequence of that social connection
i'm gonna state a position and not argue
it because it's honestly
like it's a long hard thing to argue and
we can totally do it another time if you
want
i don't subscribe to consciousness as an
emergent property
of biology or neural networks
obviously a lot of people do obviously
the
the philosophy of science orients um
towards that
in not absolutely but
largely um
i think of the nature of first person
the universe of first person of of
qualia
as uh experience
sensation desire emotion phenomenology
the but the the felt sense not the we we
say emotion and we think of a
neurochemical pattern or an endocrine
pattern
but all of the physical stuff the third
person stuff has
position and momentum and charge and
stuff like that that is
measurable repeatable i think of the
nature of first person and third person
as ontologically orthogonal to each
other
not reducible to each other they're
different kinds of stuff
and so i think about the evolution of
third person that we're quite
used to thinking about from subatomic
particles to atoms to molecules to on
and on
i think about a similar kind of and
corresponding evolution in the domain of
first person from
the way whitehead talked about kind of
prehension or proto-qualia
in earlier phases of self-organization
into higher orders of it and that
there's
correspondence but that neither like the
like the idealist do we reduce third
person to first person which is what
idealists do
or neither like the physical lists or do
we reduce first person to third person
obviously baum talked about uh
an implicat order that was deeper then
and gave rise to the explicat order of
both
um nagel talks about something like that
i have a slightly different
sense of that but again i'll just kind
of not argue how that occurs for a
moment and say
so rather than say does consciousness
emerge from i'll talk about do
higher capacities of consciousness
emerge in relationship with so it's not
first person as a category emerging from
third person but increased complexity
within the nature of first person and
third person co-evolving
do i think that it seems relatively
likely that more advanced neural
networks have
deeper phenomenology more complex where
it goes just from
basic sensation to emotion to social
awareness
to abstract cognition to self-reflexive
abstract cognition yeah
but i wouldn't say that's the emergence
of consciousness i would say it's
increased complexity within the domain
of first person corresponding to
increased complexity
and the correspondence should not
automatically be seen as causal
we can get into the arguments for why
that often is the case
so would i say that obviously the
sapien brain is pretty unique and
a single sapien now has that right even
if it took
sapiens evolving in tribes based on
group selection to make that brain
so the group made it now that brain is
there now if i take the
single person with that brain out of the
group and try to raise them in a box
they'll still not be very interesting
even with the brain
but the brain does give hardware
capacities that if conditioned in
relationship um can have interesting
things emerge so do i think that
the the human biology
types of human consciousness and types
of social interaction
all co-emerged and co-evolved yes
you